Last thing on George Santos. Anthony Davis. Okay.
Just indulge me and then we will move on for the
day. Jorge Santos claims that he developed
carbon capture carbon capture technology. I'm
not kidding. I jokingly tweeted a couple of weeks
ago that Jorge Santos actually developed a very
interesting dental technique for filling cavities.
That was not true. I was joking. But Jorge Santos
genuinely says that he played a role in developing
carbon capture technology. Listen to this.
Long story short, canceling them from the SWIFT
system is a very smart move, but it's not enough.
We need to do more. And as far as oil, we can fix
this. Bring back energy independence. The Keystone
XL pipeline. Now stop creating limits for the
permits already out there. Allow our men and women
who are out there drilling responsibly with carbon
capture technology that I've helped develop,
that fundraise for. In my career, I've had a very
extensive role in in gas and oil in this country.
And I can tell you, Rick, has far less harm to
the environment than the occasional accident.
Accidents happen. Yes. That's why they're actually
necessary in every industry. It's happened. A
banker can accidentally round up our cash,
register an ATM zero. And that changes the whole.
Yeah. This is the problem with lying. Once you
start habitually lying, you have to keep lying
to support the lies. And these are pointless
lies. They are lies of self-aggrandizement.
Carbon capture technology has been developed by
many individuals and companies and organizations.
None of them are George Santos or Anthony Alder or
whatever other names that he has used. It's you,
Dr. Klaus Lackner, a physicist. Dr. David
Keith, an environmental scientist. Dr. Julio
Friedman or Dr. Allan Wright. Rodney John
Allem. Erik Macfarlane. Jennifer Wilcox,
a chemical engineer. There are people who really
were involved in developing carbon capture
technology. Dr. Deidre Who's seen. Jorge Santos.
Anthony Dove older is not one of the people that
helped develop carbon capture technology,
and he is so far in with the reflexive lies,
the instantaneous lies that it's questionable
whether he is even able to control it. Still don't
want him in Congress. He still should resign. I am
hopeful that he will be pushed out. He is hopeful
that everybody will forget about this and move
on. We have to do what we can to prevent that from
happening. If you're curious of what Devolver
Santos looks like in these clips and you're
just listening today. Follow us on Instagram or
Facebook or YouTube where we have all of these
clips in audio visual format. For your viewing
displeasure, I think is what I would call it.